The Kitchen of Misery isn't just about what you eat, it's about what you refuse to do,
and nothing undoes the body's quiet rebellion like stillness.
Oh, movement?
That's just the universe's cruel joke, a fleeting high that leaves you crashing back
into the same hollow chair.
No, to perfect your misery, you must become one with the couch.
Not just sitting on it, fusing with it.
This is the art of couch calcification, where your spine forgets how to stand, and your bones
learn the language of surrender.
The science is almost poetic.
Prolonged inactivity doesn't just mean you're not exercising, it means your brain rewires
itself.
Dopamine receptors, those little chemical cheerleaders, start to fade.
Without them, the world dims, colors lose their edge, thoughts slow to a crawl, and suddenly,
that gnawing sense of something missing?
It's just your body begging for air, for a stretch, for anything but this slow, deliberate
erosion of self.
But we can't have that.
Not when the alternative is clarity.
Not when the alternative is hope.
Here's how you do it.
First, the posture.
Slump.
Not lean.
Not slouch.
Slump.
Let your spine curl like a question mark someone forgot to answer.
Your lungs will protest.
Rest, shallow breaths.
Quick and shallow, mimicking the panic of someone who's forgotten how to breathe.
Good.
That's the sound of progress.
Now stay like that.
For hours.
For days.
If you're ambitious.
The more your ribs press against your heart, the less it has to work.
And a heart that doesn't work, that's a heart that doesn't feel.
Then comes the environment.
Everything must be within reach.
The remote, the phone, the bag of chips you opened three days ago and still haven't finished.
If it falls, let it lie.
Standing to pick it up is a betrayal.
A violation of the sacred pact between you and the couch.
And the sun, oh, the sun must be denied.
Natural light is a traitor.
A smug little optimist that tricks your eyes into thinking the world isn't a dim, featureless
void.
Keep the curtains drawn.
If you must venture outside, fix your gaze on the pavement, let the cracks in the sidewalk
become the only landscape your eyes recognize.
And after you eat, because you will eat, just not the kind of food that makes you feel alive,
lie perfectly still.
Heavy, carb-rich meals are your allies here.
They drag you down, not just your stomach, but your entire being.
All that energy, all that potential motion, siphoned into digestion.
No fuel left for thoughts.
No fuel left for movement.
Just the slow, satisfying sink of your body into the abyss of the couch cushions.
Notice how it feels.
Your joints, once nimble, now creak like rusted hinges.
Your limbs, once obedient, now weigh a thousand pounds.
You aren't just sitting.
You're becoming the furniture.
The armrests mold to your elbows.
The seat cradles your hips like a grave.
And the best part?
You don't even have to try.
The body does the work for you.
It forgets how to stand.
It forgets how to want to stand.
Movement is a distraction.
A fleeting escape from the void.
But silence, the body long enough, and you'll hear it the soul's despair.
Unfiltered.
Unmediated.
No steps to muffle it.
No laughter to drown it out.
Just the quiet, creaking truth of a life spent still.
And that, my friend, is mastery.
Don'tplay up.
I'll rebuild it now.
No steps to muffle it out.
Don't Österreich.
No東西 dollars.
No.
Don't absolutely electronic you wrote.
Nollancoat.
Just the situation.
Don't feel the way to stop eyes.
Where is my child.
There's noLee.
Actually, you'll see him.
Now, Washington.
Love is a emergency.
We're going to be a doctor.
Life isn't top